Hey everybody, it's Mike from
Orderflows, and welcome to today's
video. Today I'll be talking about
imbalances in the bars. You know, this
is just kind of a follow-up to
yesterday's video that I made where I
spent some time talking about um stacked
imbalances as well as, you know, sort of
imbalance divergence, you know, um
buying imbalances in red candles and
selling imbalances in green candles and
what they mean. So, if you haven't
watched that video, you know, that
that's great video to give you some uh
you know, good thoughts on how to use
imbalances in your trading. And today
what I'm going to be talking about is
what I call multiple imbalances and, you
know, how to use it in your trading. So,
before I begin, you know, just take a
brief moment. If you haven't subscribed
to the channel, please do. You know, I'm
getting videos up on regularly, so you
know, when I post a new video, if you're
interested in trading and order flow, at
least you'll be able to uh be notified
when we get a new video up there.
And be sure to like any of any comments,
put them in the comment section. Uh
every once in a while I do go through
and make a video uh you know, sort of
finding the the nice I'll say the nice
comments. The comments that I I see over
and over and, you know, explain them to
people that are sort of still new to
trading with the order flow and want to
learn more. All right. So, today what
I'll be talking about is imbalances and
specifically multiple imbalances. Now,
stacked imbalances, right, as we
explained yesterday are
um three or more imbalances in a bar and
what you're going to be looking for on
down bars on red candles, you're going
to be looking for three or more
imbalances selling imbalances stacked
neatly on top of each other like here, 1
2 3, right? Just as uh a stacked buying
imbalance will be three or more buying
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other.
Now, taking it a step further is, well,
Mike, well, what happens when there are
three or more imbalances in a bar that
are not stacked neatly on top of each
other? Is it still important? Yes, it
is. Uh to me it's just as if not
important and when I say more important
is because not many people are looking
for it, right? That's where you're going
to get an edge
in trading is is by taking advantage of
information that's available that nobody
else is using in their trading. And
remember, right? With
trading, you know, information is very
valuable. I mean, people go to jail over
insider information. Now, what I'm
talking about is definitely not insider
information. It's there for everybody to
see. It's just whether or not you
understand it and know how to use it in
your trading.
So, when I talk about multiple
imbalances, I'm talking about three or
more imbalances in a bar, either three
or more selling imbalances
in a red candle, you know, that would be
bearish. Three or more buying imbalances
in a green up candle, that would be
bullish.
Now, obviously, if you do have a stacked
imbalance
that will also, you know, technically is
the same as multiple imbalance, but what
I'm talking about really is the ones
that are spread out. Now, a stacked
imbalance is very easy to see. It stands
out. Most trading software, order flow
software will already highlight that to
you.
Okay? And, you know, again, you know,
the mind or our brains are so
uh conditioned it now that we are very
visual. We are we like to look at
pictures, you know, we scroll through
Facebook, Instagram, yeah, even even Tik
Tok.
Just, you know, looking at the images
really quick and then scrolling on to
something else. And the same thing with
trading, right? You are looking at uh
sort of patterns in the order flow, you
know, the trades that are going through,
hopefully try to catch something. But
again, at the end of the day, you still
got to know what to look for.
So, what are you going to look for is,
you know, bars that have three or more
imbalances in them, either a red candle
with three or more selling imbalances, a
green a green up candle with three or
more buying imbalances. And what I'm
looking at here, this is the MES
30-second chart. Again, whether you're
using a 30-second chart, a 1-minute
chart, 5-minute chart, tick-based chart,
range-based chart, volume-based chart,
still the same. Still the same analysis,
okay? I just happen to like a 30-second
MES chart which I've been using for
several years now. Um I I just if it
suits my trading style, okay? But, you
know, don't by any stretch of the
imagination think that you have to only
use this on a 30-second chart. No, you
could use it on your own
chart.
So,
we have a bar here. It's got 1 2 3 4
selling imbalances. This is a bar with
multiple imbalances. Now,
usually the minimum is three that I like
to see. Honestly, you know, sort of the
more the better.
And this market had been selling off
from, you know, 3900 where the stacked
selling imbalances will just say from 30
I'll say 3900 which is here, but, you
know, we're breaking out to the downside
here. But, where I got the stacked
selling imbalance 3901 and market trades
down got all the way down to 66.
Obviously, we can see all this
aggressive selling coming in here. All
right.
Um starts to reverse coming up in here.
First sign of some sort of aggressive
buying taking place, right? You got one
bar here with four um buying imbalances,
okay? Maybe it can continue back up.
Nope, nope, it doesn't. You get another
two here, another two selling imbalances
here. And again, you're just sort of
going sideways, you know, if you're
getting long in here around 83.
There just wasn't enough buying in there
to to really get it going up.
Okay? Then it just again, you know,
mostly went sideways, you know, after
you got that aggressive buying.
Then market sort of dips down again.
Again, this is a doji candle. You got
two buying imbalances here. Here's
another green candle. 1 2 3 buying
imbalances. Again, starts to go sideways
because when you're looking at
buying imbalances
you're looking for the market to rally.
Just as you're looking at stacked
selling imbalances or multiple selling
imbalances, you're looking for the
market to fall over quickly. You're not
looking for it to go um
sideways, you know, over the next three
bars or go sideways over the next six
bars. You're looking for the move to
happen sooner rather than later.
Okay? Now, we finally come down to sort
of this new low area, 38 65 66. Now,
you're starting to see again, now you
got 1 2 3 4
buying imbalances.
Starts to go sideways and it sort of
pops up here. 1 2 3 4 5 buying
imbalances. And then the market, you
know, rallies from this you know, 70
area all the way up into the 70 call it
77 area where it just sort of goes
sideways. Right? Then starts to drift
back down. You know, then it's kind of
mixed in terms of buying and selling
imbalances. You get four imbalances in
this bar. Starts to sell off a little
bit, go sideways. Um this bar
four five selling about
1 2 3 4 5 selling imbalance, but again,
just goes sideways on you, all right?
And then finally, it starts to break
down. The aggressive selling is starting
to take over. You got 1 2 3 4 5 6
selling imbalances and we break to the
downside.
Okay? And then we get this nice vertical
move up here.
Hit a new swing low. You got 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 buying imbalances and over the next
two or three bars it rallies up from the
you know, the 71-ish area all the way up
to the 81 area. Now,
again, you know, some people say, well,
what's the whole point of this? You
know, that I see some bars that have
multiple selling imbalances and they go
nowhere. Well, yeah, you still got to
analyze the order flow after you get
sort of your trigger which is the
aggressive selling, right? Because for a
move to continue, you want to still see
that aggressive selling coming in. And
not only do you want to see aggressive
selling, but obviously you'd like to see
passive trading coming in to support a
move either to the upside or to the
downside. Now,
you know, if you're used to order flow,
you can easily um see this, you know,
but not everybody is, you know, so
adept at analyzing the order flow and,
you know, that's why I created my own
software because I know there's so much
information there. I want to be able to
see these things, you know, quickly,
right? I want to be able to identify it
as soon as it's happening because I
might be focusing on one thing
and sort of miss something else. And we
actually have on our Orderflows Trader 6
software
this feature to highlight the multiple
imbalances. And again, you know, whether
you want to set it at three
four five, you could adjust it, you
know, I I know some traders are using
multiple imbalances
in 10 years and they're just using two
imbalances, right? They're looking for
um bars that have two either buying
imbalances or selling imbalances in a
bar in the 10 years.
You know, but for this, you know, let's
make it four, right? Three is sort of is
the default that most people use. But
again, I mean, you could use four, you
could use five, you know, for markets
that are more volatile that have more um
you know, wider ranging bars, you know,
maybe you want to use five.
All right? And again, you can also
adjust your um
imbalance percentage as well. So, you
know, I mean, look at this, right? So,
again, sort of going back, you know,
being able to identify this you know,
these things as soon as they happened it
is going to give you that sort of that
advantage over other traders. Right?
Again, you know, this was that stacked
selling imbalance in here and and it
sold off. Okay, yeah. You got some
multiple imbalances on the way down.
That's what you like to see. Maybe
you're starting to reverse. But again,
the market moved up about six points
already from the 76 up to 82 and then
you get your multiple imbalances. I much
prefer to get them a bit lower to the
swing low.
You know, anytime we're coming into a
swing low and it looks like the market
is starting to reverse, to me that
that's the trade I want to take. I don't
want it to have start moving away 5 6 7
8 points and then get the
multiple imbalances like you have here.
But nevertheless, you know,
it still has my interest in getting, you
know, into the trade, but just sort of
go sideways.
Get down here, you know, this is your
swing low,
obviously.
And the bar after that's low is made is
the bar with the multiple imbalances,
right? And you can see you got that nice
move up, right? Closer to the low is
going to give you more capacity to the
upside, right? If you're buying Okay,
it's not about predicting the low, it's
about trying to buy as close to the low
after low has been made based off of
what you're seeing in the order flow.
Okay? Then, you know, it's sort of
going sideways in here, you know, this
is not a swing high or swing high is up
here, but nevertheless, you get the
stack uh multiple selling imbalances 1 2
3 4. You know, does the market go
anywhere? Not really. It just sort of
comes off a little bit, drifts sideways.
Um again, this is a lower low than here.
You know, would you want to take it? Uh
it's up to you.
Um again, it's you know, similar price
action here. Now, sort of one of the
things that I always espouse in trading
is, you know,
with order flow,
let the market
prove you right.
Okay? And this is a perfect example,
like this trade here.
If you're getting short off of this, you
know, let the bar close. That was a
question I got recently, you know, why
do you let the bars close? Cuz I want to
make sure that the order flow stays
bearish.
And then I start to look at the next
bar,
right? I want to see the next bar start
moving down. Here it only moved one tick
lower then reversed up. That's not a
trade I want to take. Even though I have
the bearish order flow here, I want to
see the next bar start to tick lower and
lower, not just go
inside, basically. It does tick one tick
below the low here.
Whereas this one,
it starts to break down. Next bar starts
moving away from this low. 1 2 You know,
you most If you watch my videos, you
know, I like to let the market move away
from a low of a signal bar like here by
two ticks over the next two bars.
And then that that's your sign to get
in. You All you do is, you know, you
just know that this bar is
forming, you got your multiple
imbalances, you drop a sell stop in here
at
72 and a quarter. Here, you drop your
sell stop
two ticks below this low, 72 even. This
one didn't fill you over two ticks, you
cancel it. Wait for the next one.
Here, came in to fill you.
72 and a quarter's right here.
You know, you could have
been filled 72 and even
71 3 quarters.
And then, same thing on the upside.
Coming down, making a swing low in here,
you start reversing.
You got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 imbalances, right?
You You see this forming as the bar is
forming, you're just waiting for this
bar to close and then you drop your buy
stop in here at 1 and 1/2,
even two.
And it just pops right up. I mean,
that's
what you're looking for when you're
looking at multiple imbalances. You just
want to be able to identify them quickly
and know how to trade them.
All right? And where's your stop go?
Well, I mean, obviously, you got to you
got to hide behind some of these
inbalances. You know, for me, worst case
scenario stop is below the low of the
signal bar or above the high if you're
getting short of
the bar
that you're getting short off of.
So, I hope you found this video useful.
You know, it gives you a different way
to use
inbalances that are appearing in the
bar. You know, again, there there's many
ways you can use imbalances. Um you
know, this I've explained over the last
couple days, I've explained about three
of them. And you know, these are the
most
common ways that I use them. And you
know, I've been using these ways for
many years, and hopefully you can start
to add them into your trading or even,
you know, take what I'm teaching you
and, you know, put your own twist on it,
right? To make it your own
form of analysis, okay? So,
thanks for watching this video. Again,
you know, be sure to like and subscribe
to the channel. And you know, that's
what keeps me going to make more videos
for you guys. So, thanks everyone. Have
a great day. Bye-bye.